[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui
pour entendre le message par lequel le
chef de l'état lui annoncer les accords
d'evian l'assemblée s'est réunie ainsi
début de cette semaine ce film de la
sphère d'algérie qui devait se tâcher de
sang et que nous allons dérouler devant
dans la capitale marocaine arabe a
déclaré rld enthousiasme avait salué
l'arrivée de benbella solennellement
accueillis par le roi hassan 2 venus de
tunis ou de genève le gpr à au complet
se pressaient autour de l'ex prisonnier
quelques jours plus tard monsieur
christian fouchet n'a mené au
commissaire en algérie arrivé au rocher
noir ou monsieur jean morin lui
présenter ses services dès son arrivée
monsieur christian fouchet adressait à
la population algérienne des paroles
émouvantes vous êtes en ce moment ceux
qui souffraient le plus je viens ici
pour vous aider c'est que le drame déjà
avait éclaté déjà à oran attaqué par des
commandos as les troupes ripostait dans
les rues étroites ont tiré des terrasses
sur les crs établissez le quadrillage ou
dénombré trois morts on comptait 66
blessés bilan tragique qui devait les
jours suivants s'accentuer lourdement
[Musique]
dans cette ville dont les murs
montraient des traces du combat les
fouilles opérées dans un immeuble avait
cependant permis une prise importante
l'ex-général jour le second de salles
ans disparu depuis le putsch du 22 avril
dont il avait été l'un des quatre chefs
on l'avait aussitôt transféré à la santé
mais alger couvrait sous ses murs blancs
un drame plus tragique encore bab
el-oued le vieil alger européens aux
lisières de la casbah livrer bataille
des forces régulières
folie criminelle que de tout expliquer
du désespoir g démentiel dans lequel le
sang a coulé
dans cette ville meurtrie par des
combats qui n'aurait pas dû naître on
compta des deux côtés les morts et les
blessés par dizaines et bab el-oued
réduit meurtrier fut bouclée d'un
bouclage sans fissure pendant que des
responsables et hélène maintenait
l'ordre chez les musulmans voisin
ravitailler bab el-oued bouclé bab
el-oued fouillé des caves ou greniers
bab el-oued peut être affamés devint le
souci des algérois des collectes des
quêtes s'opérait en pleine rue avant que
puisse intervenir la possibilité d'un
ravitaillement plus normal et le drame
de bab el-oued va-t-il continuer ou
plutôt tout rires l'écho des rafales de
mitraillettes ne s'est ainsi site pour
se réveiller plus loin dans ce réduit
cerner sous la menace des canons
verrons-nous s'inscrire encore d'autres
drames théron nous tomber d'autres
seront ils
c'est mort de bab el oued les derniers
d'une guerre finie qui ouvre comme le
dit le général de gaulle un nouvel
avenir et pour nous mêmes
notre référendum revêt une importance
extrême
faire et justement au sujet de la grave
à terre algérienne
la preuve éclatante de notre unité et de
notre volonté
c'est marqué que nous sommes capables de
résoudre
délibérément un grand problème de notre
temps
la france va reprendre le chemin des
urnes à ce propos une constatation lors
du dernier référendum la france a battu
un record celui de l'abstention quelque
six millions d'électeurs plus de 26 % du
corps électoral se sont abstenus c'est à
dire un français sur quatre
26%
c'est à dire le quart de la population
appelée à voter
26% qui n'ont pas dit mot soit parce que
ce jour-là la campagne sans play plus
attrayante que le bureau de vote
soit parce que c'est dans oz un vide
pressante des évents terre il a voulu
donner raison à une image d'épinal
depuis longtemps traditionnelle
soit qu'un incident imprévisible un
accident de la rue pourrait-on dire les
détourner du droit chemin
le français peuple politique n'est pas
particulièrement tardant à remplir son
devoir de citoyen chili on va arrêter
le sport ni ça les intéresse peu que les
conflits naissent ou s'éteignent que les
menaces mon tout s'apaise avec tout ce
que ces bouleversements leurs réserves à
eux mêmes car ils ont tué hier ils ont
aujourd'hui en votant la possibilité de
faire valoir leur point de vue leur wii
ou leur nom à une valeur et qu'on ne
vienne pas dire qu'est ce qu'une voix
sur 25 millions c'est oublier que ces 25
millions de voix ne sont faites que de
l'addition des voix de chacun au lieu
que l'abstention ce refus du oui ou du
non c'est la signature en blanc le
pouvoir en blanc le chèque en blanc la
liberté donnée d'agir en votre nom sans
votre contrôle et peut-être contre vous
et vous vous êtes du même coup refusé le
droit de critiquer de juger de discuter
le monde ne s'arrêtera pas pour vous
proposerez vous opposition de kennedy ou
deux coaches offre qu'elle inflexion si
minime que vous la pensiez aurez vous
donner à ces problèmes qui agitent la
nation le monde et même la vie de tous
les jours tout se fera comme si vous
n'existiez pas et avec votre approbation
puisque c'est avec votre silence
n'est dans les feuilles du jour n'y at
il que les bandes dessinées
et
[Musique]
auvergnat écrivain pamphlétaire
philosophe à cet homme de science que ne
fut pas blaise pascal
mathématicien il est un as par sa
précocité à 19 ans il inventait la
première machine à calculer
physicien ses expériences au puy de dôme
puis à la tour saint jacques sur la
pression atmosphérique sont restés
célèbres d'aucuns affirment qu on lui
doit aussi la brouette
mais sait-on qu'il fut en 1662 voici
exactement 300 ans le promoteur des
transports en commun parisiens avec la
création des 45 salle
il fallut pourtant atteindra décret de
napoléon iii pour voir s'organiser
véritablement ses transports à paris
onze compagnies faisaient alors circuler
dans la capitale quelques trois cent
cinquante huit voitures à chevaux de
toutes catégories
certains projets du reste confiante à 4
malheureux chevaux à un train entier de
voitures à six roues était restée sans
lendemain
la compagnie générale des omnibus
uniformiser les systèmes et le progrès
suivi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on vit au chara dans succédé le tramway
tracté sur rails mais on reprocher à ce
chemin de fer à l'américaine de nuire à
l'esthétique on lui préféra l'homme des
bus à impériale vint enfin les voitures
à traction automobile
nés entre temps il y avait une urgence
bienvenue le père du métro dès 1900 le
chemin de fer souterrain transformer le
sous-sol de paris en une gigantesque
taupinière le métro entre et
délibérément dans les moeurs l'idée de
pascal havet en somme fait son chemin
nous connaissons la suite familier du
métro et des autobus
nous regretterons pourtant que pascal
n'est pas sa station ce serait une
justice à l'iran
[Musique]
disparu depuis un siècle une toile de
léonard de vinci le seul ni les pins se
trouve-t-elle aujourd'hui chez un
marchand de tableaux lyonnais entre une
oeuvre d'ingres et intérêts
[Musique]
le sonic youth en effet ne doute pas
qu'ils possèdent là les dao signe
autrement dit une fortune à l'appui de
sa conviction il souligne la parenté de
l'oeuvre qu'il possède avec la toile de
léonard de vinci dont le palais borghèse
à rome détient une copie
une étude du maître florentin se
superpose d'ailleurs étrangement à la
figure du tableau le voile enfin qui
couvre pudiquement la nudité n'est qu'un
repas ultérieure la led a perdu 9 ainsi
est-elle retrouver
[Musique]
l'équipe de france de rugby maillot
blanc culotte noire le match de cardiff
contre les gallois devait être selon les
spécialistes le match du triomphe de
fait dès les premières minutes de jeu on
y croit au triomphe des français ça
commence bien pour eux les attaques
comme celle ci fusent de toutes parts
seulement voilà les colosses gallois ne
se laisse pas du tout impressionné par
la réputation de leurs adversaires et la
chance aidant les gallois prennent
avantage sur coup franc 1 0 ce sera la
plus confiné
de temps à autres lorsqu'ils ont la
balle les trois quarts français font
illusion ici il attaque avec l'arrière
claude lacaze intercalé qui donne un
coup de pied de recentrage tout cela est
très joli mais inefficace inefficace
parce qu'il manque un tout petit quelque
chose à l'équipe de france et ce petit
quelque chose c'est la chance
si l'on ajoute à cela une certaine
lenteur d'exécution et beaucoup de
maladresses on se rend parfaitement
compte que la france ne peut pas gagner
ce match et puis décidément rien ne
marche
les dernières minutes sont très pénibles
pour les français venus à cardiff pour
donner la leçon ils en sont réduits à se
défendre avant de perdre un match dont
il était pourtant archi favori
le palais des sports a offert au public
parisien un combat de poids plume qui
rappelait étrangement les grands combats
de la belle époque de la boxe en europe
pour un peu les vieux habitués des
salles parisiennes de combat se serait
cru revenu tu rentres en arrière et avec
un peu d'imagination
jean gabin n'aura pas eu de mal à se
persuader qu'il assistait à un véritable
championnat du monde de fait le cubain
sugar annonce culotte noire et de
nigériens rafiou kings sont deux
authentiques vedettes et les deux
boxeurs n'ont trompé personne ils se
sont livrées à fond du premier au
dernier rang chacun avec ses moyens
sugar amos tout en force et raf youqing
l'enfant chéri des parisiens tout en
souplesse et en décontraction le nigeria
un combat de boxe est une espèce de
petit balai un peu dilettante rafles ou
king a joué les lièvre de la fable il
s'est fait battre au sprint par amos
beaucoup plus lent que lui mais aussi
beaucoup plus régulier
non
[Musique]